et c'est là je me la vendre à un prix
cassé niveau un nom justin s'est lui
donné pour caler la donne
je dois donner après du coup vous avez
quoi de nathan qui a fallu est ce que je
peux la voir stopper la basilique
[Musique]
non
téléphone
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle juge je fais un
film sur les lieux secrets
monsieur l'inspecteur vous pouvez venir
alors qu'avez vous trouvé comment dit
bonjour je viens juste de trouver cet
indice qui concerne du trafic de cartes
pokémon au collège
nous sommes sur la trace des trafiquants
de cartes pokémon à suivre il faudra
qu'on garde de l'ethnique on mettra la
postcard dans le paquet
[Musique]
voici un autre news secret que peut-être
les trafiquants comme cachette mais à
unias pensent différemment
non c'est pas un lieu secret tout le
monde ici c'est même très ouvert on se
rassemble ici pour parler et discuter ou
pendant les récréations pour le goûter
mais rien à voir
merci à ina pour cette interview
détaillée
merci de votre fidélité à suivre voici
un autre lieu secret le sedee il paraît
que si on tire sur un livre un mécanisme
pourrait s'enclencher et cela pourrait à
ce qu'il paraît ouvrir une porte
mais bon on ne le sait pas j'ai avec moi
madame la surveillante madame la
surveillante
il paraît que vous poursuivez des
trafiquants de cartes pokémon téléphone
d'accord on va au revoir le rester
fidèle
[Musique]
re bonjour voici un autre lieu secret
l'inspecteur pense que les trafiquants
pourrait cacher leurs marchandises ici
mais entre nous
[Musique]
voici un autre lieu secret où les
trafiquants auraient pu cacher une carte
et cette carte c'est la carte de la
collection personnelle du président la
carte s'appelle go rythmique glee 2000
polytechnique
voilà c'est pas vrai c'est poche restés
fidèles et à suivre
[Musique]